the browns beat the steelers i'm so glad
i'm so glad
i'm so jesus christ i'm so sick steelers
fans
can we agree on something here
can we agree on something here
steelers fans
are the new patriot fans
okay it's the
new patriot fans they're annoying
especially when they started undefeated
this season it was
they've just been insufferable
they are insufferable
so congratulations you guys are the new
patriot fans
hope you're happy
hope you're [ __ ] happy that's what
you are so glad they lost if i to the
browns too
[ __ ] shut up [ __ ]
so [ __ ] sick of them so [ __ ] sick
of them
no no steelers fans haven't always been
like that they've been bad
but they have become insufferable
and i understand you live in pittsburgh
it's a hellscape the steel industry left
30 years ago and you guys don't know
what to do with yourselves
but say look how good my football team
is and also [ __ ] put the logo on both
sides of the helmet i know you've done
it forever on one side it's [ __ ] put
it on both
all right start with that but i think
the most fun thing i don't watch all of
it but i did watch some
some clips of it well not clips i i
watched part of the game
was that little experiment they did
where they had the saints game
the saints and bears game was on
nickelodeon did any of you guys
check this out why am i talking like a
late night talk show did you see this
did you hear about this guys
no but seriously did you guys check this
out
so the playoff game was on cbs normally
with normal announcers but then the
playoff game was also on nickelodeon
the playoff game was also on nickelodeon
and it was
oh my god
you want to talk about cringe
personified
because that was cringe personified it
was on nickelodeon look it up i swear to
god
where they had a different announced
team and then like one kid that's on a
nickelodeon show was
the third person on the announce team
and the kid on the field was in some
black kid that was
in a nickelodeon show
and like whenever they scored touchdown
to have a graphic of slime which by the
way nickelodeon's still doing the slime
thing
yeah that digital slime when they scored
exactly
but forget that you can see the clips
online i'm sure
can't play it here because even if even
if you think about the nfl they'll ban
your video go try to think about the nfl
the video will get banned go ahead
go ahead try to think about the nfl
and and the video just goes down you're
not allowed
i mean i'm more than the mba i think
more than any other thing
even if if you just
for a moment just slightly go
i'm going to think about the nfl
you're done it's over um
so you can't you can't really play
anything
uh from them so as a matter of fact here
i'll tell you what i'll do i'm going to
try and experiment here okay
no i'm going to try and experiment let's
let's see what happens
let's see what happens here
let's see all right
i'm going to really quickly okay
just to show you how how bad they are
uh i'm going to really quickly just
think about the nfl and see what happens
all right you ready you guys ready here
we go
okay here we go and i'm thinking about
the nfl
now
[Music]
all right i stopped i stopped please let
me do my show please let me do my show
i stopped okay please i apologize to the
nfl
and anybody associated with it all right
um but
the announcers
the announcers was
one of the
one of the
cringiest things i have ever witnessed
so they had you know two regular i don't
know who they were i don't know their
names and all that stuff i don't get
that into the [ __ ] and now and people
there's people that really know
all the announcers and stuff i know tony
romo because he's a good announcer in
troy because i know what he sounds like
and joe buck cause everybody hates him
they were trying to relate plays that
happen on the field like
to kid stuff like stuff the kids would
like like
i remember this vividly they were
talking about um
the the saints player
let me see what's his name um um
the the the [ __ ] the backup
quarterback that also plays tight end
uh taste some hill take some hill they
were talking about taste some hill right
taste the milk went on the play he did
something whatever
and
they they they said it's like you know
they were talking to the third the kid
who was the third
announcer they're like it's like you
know taysom hill's the kid who gets
picked first and
first in every sport like in dodgeball
and basketball because he could do
anything
and i'm like i i think
you don't need first off to still play
dodgeball but i think they
understand how it [ __ ] works i think
they
understand how the [ __ ] it works
and it was stuff like that it was just
related you know they were telling they
were saying which nfl
player who their favorite [ __ ] who
their favorite [ __ ] uh
uh cartoon this nickelodeon cartoon
character was
you aren't kidding i think someone
posted about the nfl on parlor last
night a parlor's [ __ ] gone
bye parlor